so thank you everyone for joining today
welcome to the free webinar on
metagenomics where we will be discussing
microbiome and its role in precision
medicine
in this online program we will explore
the amazing role of microbes
that we can see in human well-being
health and diseases this webinar
is for students and researchers and will
cover
the aspects of metagenomic sequencing
analysis of 16s
rrna and other aspects of microbiology
research using bioinformatics
i want to now introduce you to the
program speakers
we have elia brodsky our ceo
and co-founder at buying in his current
role he has
extensive experience working together
with
industry and academic partners that are
applying multi-omics
integration and bioinformatics to a
variety of biotechnology and clinical
applications
dr harpreet kaur is our certified omits
logic trainer and expert by information
who will guide the hands-on sessions and
assist the participants with projects
and
analysis during our upcoming training
programs
her area of specialization is cancer
genomics and machine learning
and dr mohit masumdar is our omics logic
project mentor
and an expert in big data computational
analysis
dr mazumdar has a phd in computational
biology and over 10 years of experience
working with industry and academia i now
want to invite
elia to conduct the session
and take over the session today elia
over to you
thank you sir and let me share my screen
hello and welcome to this free webinar
i'm excited to see all of you
participating today
and i hope that what we will share today
will give you a greater insight
into metagenomics itself and also hope
to introduce some of the materials and
resources that we will be making
available
in this upcoming program so as beeps
mentioned
metagenomics is a new and exciting way
to study microorganisms in their natural
environment
and so this approach allows us to really
dissect microbial community structures
but we have to also be mindful of the
way that the data is generated
and how it is used in the analysis
now these communities or microbiota
allow us to understand how different
microorganisms coexist
shape their environment and develop
a relationship with the host
we can study this microbiota to explore
species richness
and investigate the functional roles
that these microbial communities
play in many areas related to human
health
and disease
so in this webinar what you will learn
about is
the upcoming omics logic metagenomics
program
that will be starting on november 17th
this online program is designed to be
equally rewarding to both
students that are just starting to learn
about metagenomics
and researchers that are already
involved in
microbial research and it is especially
suited
for project-based learning on a flexible
schedule
so we will combine a number of different
elements to really facilitate
a flexible schedule that would make it
available
around the world and will make it
possible for you to continue and apply
these tools and methods to your own
research
the program itself will cover main
aspects of metagenomic sequencing
analysis of 16s ribosomal rna
and other aspects of microbiology
research using bioinformatics
at the end of the program all of the
participants can
opt out for independent or group
research
projects in other words you can apply
the understanding of theoretical
concepts and the practical tools
to data sets that we will help you find
and curate so we have prepared a number
of examples but you can expand on those
and apply bioinformatics tools that are
accessible to those that
do not have any technical background
don't have any coding background
and for those that want to learn how to
code we will
provide you with tools and guidance on
how to use those tools
using our python and
past scripting at the end of the program
when you have prepared your project
proposal or maybe conducted a full
preliminary research proposal
we will connect you with an expert that
will help you
evaluate the project idea and
potentially develop a competitive
proposal
that you can continue and work on after
the program is over
so what we're hoping is that the
majority of you joining today
will enjoy hearing about metagenomics
and where
the field of microbiome is going as well
as
utilize some of the resources that we
plan to make available
this month so for those of you that are
interested to learn more
in the program itself i'm just going to
ask beeps if you could
put the metagenomics omixlogic.com link
in the chat box and as we go through
this program you can explore some of the
details of the program itself
now in all of our omics logic training
programs
we combine online interactive sessions
kind of like what we are going to be
doing today
self-guided study materials that i will
briefly touch upon
and practical assignments that you can
run analysis
and understand what goes into
the different types of sequencing
analysis methods processing pipelines
and visualization tools
all together this creates an immersive
experience that we are focused on
developing
to provide excellent training in
bioinformatics now what we have found
is that many elements together become
an effective tool for thousands of
students that we have worked with
over the years and that have completed
the onyx logic training programs
to launch them into the field of
bioinformatics so even if you're coming
from a biotechnology
biology or life science programs this is
the way for you to start incorporating
bioinformatics into your expertise
which is a highly demanded skill set
in any area of life science research
today's session i am going to focus on
metagenomics
speaking mostly about the bioinformatics
analysis of metagenomic sequencing data
these methods for processing analysis
and visualization of metagenomics data
include
detailed tutorials on the use of such
popular approaches like
kind 2 data 2 and phylocy
so these are different types of
processing and visualization tools
that we will briefly touch on today but
we will speak in much greater detail
in the program that will start november
17th
but before we begin talking about
bioinformatics
let's see how sequencing technology has
helped
develop this whole field of microbiome
research
and has provided an effective view
into the study of microorganisms
and how these data analysis tools
developed for metagenomic studies
are used today to characterize
microbiota and allow us to ask
important questions about these
microbial communities
and how they develop and evolve in
association with other phenotypic
conditions that we can characterize
since the discovery of the microscope
humans have been learning about
microorganisms that surround us
and as the resolution of these
microscopes improved more
import more and more representatives of
the unseen world have been discovered
the scale of optical resolution can
reveal details
of up to one micrometer which is a
typical size of a bacteria
today microscopes are tremendously
powerful allowing us
to see smaller and smaller elements that
reveal how the world of microorganisms
functions on every imaginable surface
and importantly how microorganisms
actively interact with each other so in
this image
you can see a super high resolution
achieved with helium ion technology
that shows the process of bacteriophages
which are in green
right here so these green dots are
bacteriophages that are attacking e coli
bacteria the blue
are the e coli bacteria so you can see
how this interaction is happening in
real life just because
just between two members of this
community of microbiome community
microbiota
representing a virus or a phage
and a bacteria now the connection
between disease and microorganisms has
been established in the 1800s and
already towards the
end of the 19th century laboratory
methods for growing microorganisms in a
lab culture were developed
helping characterize them with staining
these studies provided
important information about bacterial
function in
isolation however it was soon apparent
that most microorganisms
in fact live in complex communities
and it was soon discovered that many
members of these communities
are actually not possible to culture in
isolation in a lab
so today we know that the microorganisms
or the microbiota
in collection that make up the human
microbiome
are not just unicellular organisms
living alongside each other but instead
form highly regulated structurally and
functionally organized communities
attached to surfaces as biofilms with
interspecies collaborations
as well as antagonisms that contribute
to
its ecological stability
due to the advances in metagenomic
sequences
sequencing and other omics technologies
and enormous databases of sequencing
data
from such communities has led to the
emergence of computational metagenomics
which can help study the remaining 99
of unculture unculturable microorganisms
in the context of their natural
environment so you can see here
a brief timeline how
in the mid 1600s first observations of
micro microscopic organisms
were published and then the connection
has been made between disease
and microorganisms and then from
the 1800s until now this
practice of staining and microscopy has
been used
to study different isolated
microorganisms
eventually in the 1980s unculturable
microorganisms
are started were started to be studied
using dna sequencing
in 2008 an important milestone actually
started in 2007
the human microbiome project was
launched and has provided as we will see
in the future slides
an expansive database of sequences of
different microorganisms
and so starting from 2010 up until now
so the past
decade and onward we are seeing the
important and critical
role of bioinformatics or computational
biology tools
to study the communities in the context
of this era of multi-omics data sets
now the stability of these communities
is fascinating as many of us probably
know from
trying to battle such common skin
conditions as eczema
acne and dry skin these communities
form distinct communities the
microorganisms
in a microbiota are interconnected and
determined to maintain their community
bacteria within a biofilm can
communicate with each other by producing
detecting and responding
to small diffusible signal molecules in
a process called
quorum sensitive which confirms benefit
for host colonization
biofilm formation defense against
competitors
and adaptation to changes in the
environment
quorum sensing activities in biofilms
are also involved in the virulence
and pathogenic potential of bacteria and
are therefore an important factor
in understanding and controlling
bacterial infections
as they enable microorganisms and
biofilms to become
more tolerant of host defenses and
antimicrobial agents
so inside each community there's a
balance in fact of bacteria
fungi and viruses and together they
control species abundance
and the activity of that particular
microbiota
the human microbiota is estimated to be
10 to the 13th to 10 to the 14th of
microbial cells so
trillions of cells with around one to
one microbial cells to
human cells ratio even though it was
previously reported that there is a much
greater number of microorganisms about
one to ten these figures have been
updated not so long ago by sandra al
in 2016. these numbers
are derived from the total bacterial
cells in
colon which is 3.8 to the 10 to the 13th
of bacteria
the organ that harbors the densest
number of microbes
however each one of these microorganisms
carries
an important functional property in
genes that contain
genomic information on metabolites and
proteins that these microorganisms
produce
these properties and the genomic
information about microorganisms
have been a growing interest to the
scientific community
resulting in over 80 000 publications
over the years
the majority of these studies have been
focused on the intestinal microbiome
but more and more additional
relationships between
the composition of microbiota and
different conditions
has been emerging since the 1990s
microbiome studies were significantly
advanced
through such major initiatives as the
metagenomics of the human intestinal
tract
and the subsequent human microbiome
project these are
tremendous huge investments and studies
that have been made possible
through the advances in metagenomic
sequencing
so as a result skin lung gut and even
brain microbiota
are starting to be characterized in
great detail
each new project represents vast
opportunities
as well as challenges to determine which
microorganisms play
key roles in the development of certain
environmental conditions
needed for healthy function of human
organs and which can be actually harmful
to such communities over the past decade
more than 1.7 billion has been spent on
human microbiome
research major projects are underway in
the united states
european union china canada ireland
south korea and japan
this investment has confirmed the
importance of microbiome to human health
and development
it is now known for instance that
newborns receive
essential microorganisms from their
mothers
moreover the sugars in breast milk that
infants cannot digest
nourish babies developing microbiomes
which in turn
shape their immune systems the biggest
investment by far
around one billion dollars came from the
united states
about 20 percent of this has gone to two
phases of the human microbiome projects
you can see right here which is creating
the research resources needed for
studying the human microbiome
one of the main goals of the human
microbiome project launched in 2007
was to create a toolbox of reference
data sets
computational techniques analytical
methods and clinical protocols
this seems to have been a major success
about 75 percent
of the 2012 to 2016 nih grant recipients
for microbiome research
outside of the hmp is working on more
than
100 different diseases this
decided reliance on hmp data and tools
in their funding applications so it's
becoming clear
that microbes are needed to support
human development and maturation
and to activate and maintain stability
in the immune system
and metabolism but there are still many
things that we don't understand
for example we don't understand how
these fundamental biological phenomena
involving human cells and microbes
co-evolved
what's even more important some
ecological concepts
are not yet commonly considered in the
studies of the human microbiome
these include how communities of
microbes operate
as a whole how keystone species
can pave the way for others by altering
local conditions
and the predator-prey relationships
between different microbes
developing a new conceptual framework
and applying it to the human microbiome
will require
much more collaboration between
investigators working
across desperate fields including
evolution
ecology microbiology biomedicine
and computational biology or
bioinformatics
it will also demand significant changes
in how data and other resources
are distributed between scientists and
importantly it will
require a good communication between
those coming from the computational
field
those coming from the health sciences
field and those coming from basic
research
because right now these are very
separate
areas of microbiome research and we see
that they all enter real interrelate
allowing many of these findings to come
and be tested and become clinically
important so
we know today that the microbiome
function
is important for many areas of human
development
health and disease and it's because of
this huge investment of capital
and human research time that we now know
that the endogenous human microbial
communities
contribute to critical metabolic
physiological
and immunological functions that include
differentiation maturation of the host
mucosa and its immune system
food digestion and nutrition energy
generation
metabolic regulation and control of fat
storage
processing and detoxification on the
environmental chemicals
maintenance of skin and mucosa barrier
function
development and regulation of the immune
system and fine
tuning of its reaction pattern or the
balance between pro-inflammatory and
anti-inflammatory processes and the
prevention
of invasion and growth of
disease-promoting microorganisms
for example colonization resistance
so an important underlying technology
that connects many of these
studies are being answered using next
generation sequencing
as well as other types of omics data for
example
mass spectroscopy proteomics and
metabolics indeed it seems that
the future the next phase of prominent
microbiome research
lies in the ability to integrate
multi-omics data sets that combine
next generation sequencing mass spec and
structural data
with phenotypic information about
overall changes
in the community and their environment
so to understand the challenges
and the changing nature of such data
let's take a look
at some of this data and how it could be
integrated
so here we can see an approach to
integration
where you can see the immune system and
health
indicators being studied in the response
to different types of treatments
so you can study the before and after
and
time course conditions to understand how
samples represent different types of
microbes
and their changes over time and you can
study that using
dna sequencing rna sequencing so the
expression of specific genes
metaproteomics or which proteins are
actually being produced and how they
interrelate to each other and
importantly
metabolite sequences or sorry
metabolites
so all of this has to be integrated
using data integration approaches
that look at the detailed structured
data sets
and then finding network associations
which you can see right here
between the different species and the
products
of their function this is an
important and emerging area of my
multi-omics integration that has to do
with precision medicine which is really
becoming an important
part of many areas of omics research
so i'm going to pause right now and take
a look at some of the questions that i
see in the chat
and answer any of the questions that you
might have
about what we have done up until now
okay so if you have any questions and
beeps if you could
help me identify any questions that have
already been
posed i'm ready to answer any questions
that people might have right now
okay yes celia so we have one from
modibu
he's asking i'm working about autism i
would like to know the specific
microbiomes associated to autism
okay so modibu thank you for the
question indeed
autism and other neurodegenerative
diseases
have been linked to different indicators
i think what's important
to understand is that many of such
studies are
in their early stages and one of the
things that you can derive from data
sets that are already available are some
associations
now association is not necessarily
causality
and so that's one of the things where we
will talk about in
a few slides from now we will be talking
about
how such causal
associations could be studied using
animal modeling
so we will talk about animal models of
human microbiome composition
and how those have been used to study
different
psychological neurodegenerative diseases
thank you elia we have another question
from shraddha
my area of research is breast cancer how
can i study microbiome in relation to it
or the influence of it in breast cancer
okay excellent question so in fact
breast cancer and other
cancers have been linked to tumor micro
environment there are many publications
on these topics but also importantly
how the microbiome is affected by
different types of chemotherapy
and targeted therapy because many of the
functions of the immune response are
linked to microbiome
many of the cancer treatments are
related to the immune response
so those are important areas of research
now we're not going to definitively
answer these questions in this short
presentation
but in the course of the upcoming
program
what we will do is we will take these
data sets and publications that present
the
evidence from sequencing data and you
will be able to
analyze those data to find such
association so i think if that is an
interest
i will definitely point today to how to
easily find such data sets
and what are some of the common tools
that are used to find
such associations
thank you so much elia and if you have
any specific projects that you are
going to work on i just want to take one
minute you can actually reach out to us
at marketing at pine dot bio
for any such uh queries and we will be
able to help you out because
uh it's not always possible to address
all the questions in this one
session uh either for the next question
we have one from newport
are these networks a part of network
pharmacology
okay excellent question so this will be
the last question for now and i'll
move on after this but network
pharmacology
seeks to establish how specific
active compounds can affect
the overall systems biology which of
course works as a network or could be
represented by a network of nodes that
are interrelated by the edges in the
network
studying such networks and the changes
in the networks
is a field of its own that allows us to
understand how the perturbations of the
network
can help reveal some of these prominent
and strong associations
so what we will be talking about today
are some general approaches
to such types of data integration and
analysis
in bioinformatics and it could
definitely be applied to
pharmacological studies as well where
you take essentially
drugs combinations of drugs different
dosages apply them to different
individuals and then study how those
are change how the responses of those
individuals are
changing because of their for example
microbiome
or microbiome host pathogen
relationships how do those
actually are affected so we won't talk
about this topic
in detail right now but we will
definitely expand
on such studies in the context of the
program
now in uh in the current presentation
i'm going to move on for right now
please continue posting your questions
on the chat we will pause for another
few minutes
after a few more slides to address some
of the changes
sorry some of the questions that you
have uh
posted in the chat so thank you for your
questions
so let's talk a little bit about one
types of one type of such data
metagenomics obviously metagenomics
is a predominant technique used to study
microbiome because it allows us to study
the sequences now metagenomics
as a field can be defined as the genomic
analysis of microbial dna from
environmental communities metagenomics
tools
enable the population analysis of
unculturable
or previously unknown microbes this is
very important because
only one to two percent of bacteria can
be actually cultured
in the lab the ability to identify
microbes without a priori knowledge of
what sample
contains is opening new doors in
disciplines
like microbial ecology virology
microbiology environmental sciences and
many areas of biomedical research
sequencing based examination of the
metagenome
has become a powerful tool for
generating novel hypotheses
now metagenomics as opposed to
other types of omics really represents a
different
approach for example genomics proteomics
transcriptomics all focus
on whole of a single organisms but
metagenomics allow us to study a
collection of
organisms that live in communities and
interact so we're really when we are
approaching
the question from a metagenomics
perspective
we are looking at how the community
composition
diversity is changing in response
to different types of phenotypic data
metagenomic sequencing itself can be
applied
to environmental culture free sequencing
to study populations
as well as for detailed extraction of
genomic variation
and the expression of genes from the
microorganisms
after culturing in the lab and often
times when we speak about
metagenomics we are speaking about those
two technologies actually
combined together so here you can see on
top an example of
you taking a sample from the gut
and then looking at culture free
sequencing reads where we can
look at otus which i'll speak about in a
second here
to understand taxonomic classification
now importantly in some examples you can
take
and culture some dominant species or
representatives of this community
to then map onto the reference genome
and understand variation
in those types of sequences so for
example we can discover
how antibiotic resistance how changes
in the specific function of the genes
produced by the most abundant species in
the microbiome
could be linked to this taxonomic
classification
to understand how the whole community
is affected by such changes
now the important technology that we're
going to be talking about a lot
is what's called 16s metagenomic
sequencing
which is a technique that has been
fairly well established because of many
benefits
for micro microbiome studies
it is widely used to study microbiome
directly in its environment
and it focuses on the 16s
ribosomal rna that has to be amplified
with pcr
amplification the 16s gene sequences
contain
what's called hyper variable g regions
also known as hvrs
that provide specific signature
sequences
that are very useful for bacterial
identification in the
taxonomy of all bacterial species
the benefit of amplification is tied to
the nature of sequencing
read length which can maximize the
effective
output from affordable sequencing
technologies
now we mentioned hyper variable region
so
hyper variable regions allow us to
understand
how different communities look at
the different types of microbial
organisms that are present now there's
too much of a diversity to really study
those individually so instead
we can characterize them by organizing
them
into operational taxonomic units or otus
so this is an operational definition
that is used to classify
groups of closely related individuals
otu classification can be done using
several different computational
approaches
hierarchical clustering algorithms
bayesian clustering
or phylogenetic analysis based on
multiple sequence alignments
once those otus are identified
as you can see in this example right
here and they are categorized by some
common variation
that is common to all the different
species that are present and carry this
otu
then we can apply mapping onto
databases and there are several
databases that have been
regularly updated and used in such
metagenomic research
one of these is the silva database which
contains
taxonomic information for the domains of
bacteria
archaea and eukarya it is based
primarily on phylogenies for small
subunit ribosomal rnas or the 16s for
prokaryotes and 18s from for eukarya
taxonomic rank information for archaean
bacteria
is obtained from burglary's taxonomic
outlines
and from the list of prokaryotic names
with standing in
nomenclature lpsn whereas eukaryotic
taxonomy is based on the consensus views
of the international society of
protestologists
taxonomic rank assigned in the silva
database are manually curated
and for comparison it was it was seen
that silva is one of the more reliable
consistent and up-to-date databases
compared to some of the other ones
like the green genes the ribosomal
database
project or rdp and ncbi
so it's important to understand what
this taxonomy
allows us to see when we analyze data
applying mapping onto such databases
for example here you can see the
hierarchy of biological classification
many of the otus lack annotation
at the lower levels like species genus
and family
so a lot of times the characterization
of a community
can be comprehensively done at the
higher levels like
phylum and kingdom now in the phylum
level we can start looking
at how different microbial communities
vary
between different organs and here we're
talking about some healthy microbiota
found on the human body so you can see
here some examples of phyla
like fermicutes actinobacteria bacteria
deets
proteobacteria and fusobacteria and how
they
vary between some of the commonly
studied
organs in the human body now you can see
for example
the colon as compared to the skin
the colon contains the majority of
proteobacteria
as opposed to the skin which contains
the majority of
actinobacteria we can look at it from
this level to understand
what might be the environment that is
caused by such
composition and we can study changes in
this
healthy composition across many
individuals
to determine any effect of common
changes in health and pathology that is
observed
on these organs now importantly
the bacteria are not the only
components of this microbiome
or the microbiota importantly we have
also
the viral which is actually one part of
the microbiome and constitutes
all of the organisms that inhabit us
including bacterial and archaeal
organisms as well as the microbiome and
other members of the mayo fauna
such as protists and metazoans studies
of the virum are also in their
infancy because it has only recently
become possible
to see the viron in large sequence
datasets
using advanced bioinformatics tools that
can detect relationships between viruses
despite their extreme nucleotide
sequence diversity
now the size of the mammalian viral is
not even known as opposed to microbiome
and bacteria
the viral composition is not really
that well characterized although our own
cells amount to similar quantities
as the bacterial members of the human
microbiomes
human feces alone contain 10 to the 8
viruses per gram additionally the
mammalian viral
is continuously updated through rapid
evolution of viruses
and through exposure to viruses in the
environment
or in other mammals that we interact
with
now importantly we can also apply
metagenomic sequences
to understand presence and composition
of viral bacterial composition in a
sample so here you can see
some of the common sequencing techniques
that produce a characterization
of some of the common prevalent viruses
that also play
a major role in the composition of the
microbiome because the microbiome
is a protective layer and controls the
replication of some of these
harmful pathogens but also in the
different diseases that they cause
now some of these viruses are very
prevalent
in cancers and they also represent an
important part of the interaction
with the human microbiome so what we
will talk
in the context of the program a little
bit is how
some of these viruses like the
epstein-barr virus
human papilloma virus and hepatitis
viruses
cause important cancers that are
a huge burden on the human well-being
and health so let's talk about a few
practical examples in the
program we will talk about each one of
these examples
in greater detail and so after i go
through these examples i think i will be
able to address some of your questions
in a little bit more detail based on
what the information that we present
here
a big part of the human microbiome
project
is the american gut project so you can
see here a link
let's actually take a look at this link
quickly together
so i'm going to just post this in the
chat
so we'll go to this american gut project
okay so it seems like their website is
down so let's instead
go here so you can see how
american gut is a very interesting
project because it actually
involves not just a comparison of
healthy and sick people
but seeks to characterize microbiome
very variability
based on multiple factors that are
self-reported
by uh citizen scientists so essentially
any one of us can participate in this
american gut project
by paying for a small fee for sequencing
but essentially
reaping the benefit of comparing our own
microbiome
and our self-reported traits like ethnic
background
the foods that we eat how often we
exercise
whether we get sick regularly or not and
really to try to establish
some common links between microbiome
composition and such traits
across a huge diversity of people now
importantly
this microbiome project is now expanded
well beyond
the us it involves such places like
canada and even europe
and any one of you that is interested to
participate can follow through this
publication
to understand how these communities vary
and what are some of the important
associations that are emerging from the
study of this microbial composition
so let's take a look at an example this
is actually a report that
one might get from producing that kind
of sequencing so you get a kit
and you sample different areas on your
body
using these swabs sending them over to a
central lab
where that sequencing is performed and
based on the analysis of such sequences
you can see
how your sample compares to some of the
other samples that are already in this
database
now what we will do in the program is
take several samples like these
to produce a report exactly like this so
that will give you some hands-on
practical
work experience dealing with
samples that come from healthy
and sick people that have contributed
their own samples to this database
now another important area of research
is how does the specific microbiome
composition affect different areas
of normal subnormal and
clinical conditions in some cases like
gut microbiome
we can sample clinical patients and find
associations with
clinical conditions of the microbiome
composition changes
but in many cases it is very difficult
to have a controlled environment
where such changes could be studied and
a good example
is the link between obesity
which is a phenotypic condition the
microbiome
which is difficult to necessarily link
to this phenotypic condition anxiety
which is a physiological but more
psychological condition
and to really establish a link and so
to address this challenge there have
been a number of
animal models that have been developed
to really elucidate
the direct connection between microbiome
changes
and such conditions the way it was done
and we'll take a look at this kind of an
example in greater detail
is we'll take this publication that's
called obese type gut microbiota
induce neurobehavioral changes in the
absence of obesity
now the way that they performed this
experiment
is they took early young
mice at three months old that's when the
microbiome is being
developed they then reduced
the bacterial load so they really reduce
the composition the complexity
of the microbiome did some behavioral
testing
and developed a model where you can see
how different
recipients of microbiome composition
from these donors that were uh at a
young age established on a specific diet
can lead to actual characterization of
changes in microbiome
and links to their behavioral changes
as well now the way such studies could
be done
is by employing what's called
bioinformatics
analysis pipelines so what do these
pipelines
actually look like the way it is done is
that at
each stage you get some samples
and these samples represent a community
that could be characterized by
operational taxonomic unit diversity
and composition so let's take a look at
how
this is done to take a look at a
practical example
we're going to be using the analysis of
16s
amplicon data which is a study that we
just described
from that paper an actual data set from
that paper
where you can analyze sequencing data
using the data to pipeline
so to take a look at this practically
please go with me to
server.tdashbio.info
okay this is a platform that we commonly
use
in our analysis logic so what is
important to understand
is not only how this data is produced
and what types of studies are out there
what types of data sets are out there
but really to see how does the data
become informative how do we reveal
information
and what kind of information is it going
to be
so this is the platform that we use
for training but it's also a research
tool that you can use in your analysis
of metagenomic sequencing data now if
any one of you would like to get
a quick demo i'm going to do this to
just
showcase what it would look like but you
can also request a demo
account from pizza here on chat
and then you will be able to follow
along
so down here i'm going to just show you
this section the amplifon 16s 18s
section and we have a demo pipeline here
that i will just briefly go through
so that we don't have to analyze the
data
in real time so this is pre-analyzed
data
so this is what's called the data 2
pipeline and it
is an important tool for simplifying the
diversity
by merging high quality reads into
operational taxonomic units
that are mapped onto a reference
database
and then we can visualize that
information using
phyloseq so i'm going to create here a
very simple
pipeline that will look at hypervariable
regions
v4 and v9 you can see this is the
16s ribosomal rna so there's
v4 and here we have
v9 right here these are hyper variable
regions that are commonly used to
characterize
diversity in metagenomic sequences
the data 2 pipeline as i mentioned is an
important
tool that allow us to remove all kinds
of artifacts that can lead to false
positives and false negatives
in the way that we characterize the
composition
now this noise is an important challenge
in all
metagenomic sequencing so here what we
will do is we will take a few steps
to really reduce the noise and make sure
that we create cluster samples that are
consensus otus
remove chimeras and then use mapping
onto a database
by assigning taxonomy to these samples
after this is done we are going to
identify
relationships between these otus by
analyzing phylogenetic relationships
using
ape so what ape does is it
forms a relationship based on multiple
sequence alignments
of these otus and then we can visualize
this data
by using a commonly used package in
r called phyloseq so here you can see
differences in compositions and what is
useful in filoseq is that it produces
some
standard visualization tools and we'll
talk about
how that is done in just a second to
help us
understand the variability between these
different samples
so to illustrate what we will typically
get
out of it are several pdf files
that allow us to visually understand
what we have found
so first of all i am going to look at
the scores
of read quality so here you can see the
read quality
the read quality is important for us to
understand
what is the actual level at which
the cutoff of the threshold of read
quality is done
you can also see the results so this
quality of reads is actually done by the
data 2 pipeline
and then once we have high quality data
we can start
analyzing that using phyloseq so here we
have the phylo seek results
so the phyloseq results allow us to look
at composition
what does this composition actually look
like
the composition here you can see it is
done by family so this is a very
good level of composition and you can
see how
we have diversity between different
samples and so here we have the samples
here we have the abundance or this is
proportional abundance
of different families of microbiomes
including some unknown ones that were
not characterized
this kind of an abundance can actually
characterize diversity based on
alpha and beta diversity so alpha
diversity
and beta diversity allow us to look at
composition within samples and between
samples
this is not just simply done based on
the abundance about to use
but also on the phylogenetic
relationships between
individual otus representing
species richness or how diverse
each sample is and how that diversity
changes
between groups of samples so here you
can see
the chao one and the shannon metrics for
alpha diversity and you can see how
those samples
vary in those diversity matters as well
as you can see
right here right here you can see beta
diversity
which is done by non-metric
dimensionality scaling
which is that which is showing us a real
clear difference
between the samples that are done on
regular diet that have been grown based
on regular diet
and those that have been grown on high
fat diet
really that illustrates how we can
understand
the relationship between microbiome
composition
and the relationship with a phenotype
that we can actually characterize or
study
using a psychological test
okay let me just give you a couple more
examples
and then i will open this up for
questions again
an important part of such studies has
allowed us
to understand how different types of
conditions
including changes in diet
and including in the changes
in treatments have led to important
discoveries
about the microbiome for example one
such discovery
was made on the effect of microbiome
changes in the composition and
alzheimer's disease so in fact
you can see here in 2019 the
china has approved alzheimer's disease
treatment that targets the microbiome
so these are very important new
discoveries that have been done
in the context of microbial studies
based on
a association with human
samples as well as samples that were
designed in animal experiments
another important result of such studies
is the effect of cancer therapy so
anti-cancer treatment modalities and
co-medications
we know that they affect the integrity
of the epithelial
barrier they also affect the actual
microbial
composition so you can see here how
the different changes in microbiome that
affect the immune response
that affect the integrity of different
organs and the protective films that
these microbiota
form as well as the actual direct impact
on the immune cells
involved in responses so as a result
we can identify microbial signatures
as you can see here below that actually
will help determine whether a particular
cancer treatment
will be effective and to track the
effectiveness of such
treatment over time of the course of
treatment potentially
changing the course of treatment or
seeking to modulate the microbiome
composition
to prepare to kind of prep up
the patient for effective consumption of
treatment
for particular diseases okay
so these were just a few examples i know
that there are a lot of questions about
other types of examples that could be
done so let me focus right now on some
of the questions that you've posted on
the chat pizza if you could
help me sort through the questions so i
could respond to the
important ones yes sure elia
so we had one from shraddha earlier
so do the microbiome of normal person
differ from diseased one
yes so obviously there's a lot of
variability
between what we call normal people right
we know that normal people
consume different foods they grow up in
different
environments even drinking different
water
so all of those things change the way
the microbiome develops as was shown
in this example with animal models where
transplanted microbiota actually
led to specific types of changes in
behavior
now those would not necessarily
categorize a person
as a non-healthy or a clinically sick
person
but it definitely changes susceptibility
to diseases
changes the response to different
pathogens and as we can see here
changes the response to different
treatments so obviously
there's a lot of diversity to sort
through before we define
whether there's an association with a
clinical condition
now some clinical conditions have very
clear-cut changes for example
irritable bowel syndrome or ibs
different other types of sensitivities
of the gut
more and more of such changes are weaker
links
so they're really just a component in a
complex systems biology
relationship between a clinical
condition
and the microbiome so i think we have to
put it into context if that answers your
ques
a question if not you can maybe clarify
now i do see that modibo here put a
question
privately to me so i will just read that
out
how can we simulate in silico the repair
genes interactions with mutated gene or
for dna
reparation and which server or
bioinformatics could do it
so if i understand correctly the
question
the repair genes dna repair genes
and mutations in dna
is what the question is all about so
maybe a scenario or a project example
here is to think of cancer
so we can think of cancer oftentimes
caused by somatic mutations somatic
mutations are repaired by
repair genes and so mutations in repair
genes
and accumulation of somatic mutations in
the dna
eventually causes cancer now how can we
simulate the interactions between the
repair genes
and dna mutations so i think that
you need to develop a mechanistic model
that really defines all of the
relationships but
before you define that model that model
should be data driven so i think the
first
part of it is to really take some
sequencing data
that combines gene expression and
mutation data so you can look at
accumulation of mutations or
presence or absence of particular
somatic mutations and the expression of
genes and really
the interaction could be studied by
what's called multi-omics integration
the server that i just demonstrated the
server
tbioinfo server.tbioinfo
has a number of sections for both
multi-omics
integration so you can see right here
multi-omics integration that
seeks to take two different types of
omics data and study relationships
within
this multi-atomic data set using
different approaches for example
integration based on part-time networks
or bipartite
networks or clustering and other types
of approaches so that's
one way to study the interactions
once you develop a mechanistic model
there are a number of
uh mathematical modeling tools that we
also have
and that typically involves mathematical
simulation so once a mathematical model
is developed you can simulate that model
now that's a very complex process of
actually
making that model first and maybe
testing the model prediction on data
so if you are interested in that we do
have a section related to that but i
think we would need to
understand a lot more what the actual
project
is about to uh to really help you
okay any other questions
yes celia we have one from dr manov jain
can there be temporal relationship
between
duration for which microbiome is altered
and development of disease for how
long microbiome should remain altered
so it's a great question i would assume
that question would be more directed to
a microbiologist i myself am not a
they more um can address the questions
about the bioinformatics
uh component here so i think what would
be
a good approach to try to answer that
question is to find a specific data set
and i'm actually going to get to that
point
in just a few minutes so maybe we can
uh take the remainder of the questions
and just
email them to us we would be happy to
continue this interaction after the
webinar
to really help you identify project
examples
existing data sets and link them with
effective tools that will help you
try to find some answers to these
questions and
if you are a microbiologist and you're
interested in trying
to apply metagenomic sequencing data
analysis tools
to answer such questions i think there
are
a wide variety of publicly available
data sets and that's the exciting part i
think in
in silico studies and computational
biology studies that we have access to
such great
uh microbial data sets that we can
analyze so i will get to that in
just a second in just a few minutes sir
okay so we talked about a few examples
and again
thank you for your questions i think
these are excellent questions
um i do want to mention that the program
that we are going to be launching on
november 17th
is going to be designed for those of you
that have such
questions and would like to work with
different types of data
including metagenomic sequencing and
other types of omics data
to be able to answer such data such
questions that you have so let me talk
briefly
about this upcoming omics logic
metagenomics program
that will be starting november 17th
the online program again is designed to
help students as well as researchers and
faculty
to try and address such questions with
bioinformatics analysis so the objective
of the program is to help you
develop an independent project maybe
trying to answer
some of the questions that you have
already posed in this chat
leveraging the tools and the data that
we will
discuss and develop practical skills
with so that anyone can actually use
them
so the program is designed to really
highlight the role of
big omics data that is shaping modern
biomedical innovation
where molecular data is used for
precision diagnostics
big data integration and machine
learning are transforming
personalization of treatment selection
and innovative algorithms allow for
unprecedented capabilities
with drug discovery drug design as well
as repurposing and so the important part
is that these various types of omics
data
that we describe in great detail
intracellular and
intercellular processes associated with
common diseases
they have to be analyzed to understand
understand the biology behind
host factors and microbiome composition
in our bodies and the environments that
we live in
to drive infection and cause deteriorate
deterioration of health
to destabilize the immune system and
lead
to clinical manifestations of disease so
these multi-omics data sets require
different
approaches to the processing integration
visualization and interpretation and the
objective of the program
is to give you a sense of how these
different methods and tools could be
applied
directly to study microbiome or the host
responses to find links and associations
with some of the clinical data that we
have about patient interactions with
their clinicians
so the objective of the program again as
i mentioned is to provide
a platform for you to think about find
develop projects that are independent
and get some feedback
from participant experts in the panel
that will actually help evaluate and
help you refine some of the ideas that
you might already have
so really at the end of this program you
will be able to present a project to a
panel of experts
here we will bring in some experts that
have experience with metagenomic
sequencing data analysis
they will be able to help guide prepare
you and then evaluate your project
proposal
now the objective of these omixlogic
programs is to provide you with a clear
perspective
on big data analytics machine learning
and artificial
intelligence so that anyone can try and
apply
a variety of different analysis methods
and to do that obviously it's very
important to have access to curated data
sets
so what we will do in the context of
this program
is actually look at such public
repositories like
the human microbiome project the
american gut
project we will look at different
disease-specific
metagenomic data sets and a lot of the
tools that you will gain will
allow you to effectively search ncbi
the national center for biotechnology
information
and identify data sets that are ready
for analysis our previous participants
have developed a number of research
projects together
in this program that have led to poster
presentations
publications grant applications for
those that are already in research
where you can leverage bioinformatics to
define some
interesting preliminary results and
those preliminary results can define the
way that you are thinking
about a particular research question so
to summarize
what we've learned today is an important
part
in this emerging field of microbiome
research that has
far reaching implications for different
types of conditions that are both
clinical
psychological environmental and others
and for you to get started on this
journey we are excited to present
this six session program
this program is designed to help you get
started
if you are coming from a life science
background or you're coming from a
computational background
it's really designed to launch you into
this field of metagenomics
so let me describe this data this
program a little bit
to explain how you can join
and what you can take away from this
program
so first of all the link to the program
itself where you can see
in much greater detail all of the
different elements that i am describing
now
is metagenomics.omixlogic.com
so this program itself we can take a
look here
together what it will cover
you can see the dates for this program
a short overview of the program and here
you will see
some of the specific topics that will be
covered in each one of the sessions
as well as some of the asynchronous
resources
and some of the specific project
examples that we will go through
as well as some of the tools that we do
not have time to showcase
in this session because we're already
running
over time but you can definitely see
a lot more information about this
program on this link
now briefly going through some of the
sessions and what will be covered these
are interactive training sessions
we will talk about the specifics of the
program
and what type of resources that you will
get these include
big data analysis tools on the cloud
include
asynchronous resources that you can do
on your own time
interactive sessions where we will do
assignments together
including coding and running some
pipelines as well as some feedback from
experts that will help
guide your independent project and
refine your ideas
as you're trying to look for a
particular data set we will talk in
detail about metagenomic sequencing and
guide you through an asynchronous course
where you can
learn about the individual terminology
and the different types of concepts that
are important to know
we'll talk about mapping on databases
and visualizing the sequencing data in
a cloud-based environment then we'll
talk about
how to study variability and composition
including some important pipelines that
are that are considered to be the gold
standard
like data 2 and kind 2.
we'll then talk about some of the
examples that we talked about
uh here briefly the american gut project
and the human
microbiome project as well as such
animal model studies like the microbiome
diet
and the association with the gut brain
access
finally we will help you develop an
independent
project from publicly available data
sets that you will be able to define
and develop a proposal potentially even
getting some preliminary results that
you can showcase
finally we will talk about some expert
feedback
for that project now
for the program we will leverage some
online tools and in our next session
when we do the introduction to this
program and that will be a free webinar
that all of you are welcome to join
we will actually go through the
different types of the synchronous
materials
and discuss the scheduling and how to
get started
so the program will start on november
17th
i hope that this webinar is somewhat
informative and i was able to answer at
least some of your questions
we do have a blog post on the different
types of
applications of metagenomics in
different types of
communities like the skin the
risk of dementia autoimmune diseases
some of the
ways that you can culture and study
bacteria in the lab
so if beeps say you could place a link
to that blog so if any one of you
is interested in the different types of
projects that we will discuss
you will find those discussed on this
link
importantly i think that what we are
trying to establish here as a company
is not just the training itself and not
just providing you with
cloud-based tools that you can use an
important component i think of these
programs
are the community that we are building
and this community
includes students young faculty and
researchers
as well as established faculty and
professionals
that will help you understand the
applications of metagenomics and
microbiome research
in important basic and translational
research projects
so we always welcome those of you that
are interested
in omixlogic to join our social media
groups
and one of them is called the omixlogic
group on
linkedin you can see here the link to
the linkedin group
in fact i'm going to just copy these and
paste them here in the chat
as well as a facebook group that you
will see
includes thousands of participants from
around the world
that will join some of the programs that
we have
and there are many different programs
that we have throughout the year
not just focused on metagenomics but
also focused on
other omics fields as well as data
science skills
and specific research areas like
infectious diseases
or precision medicine thank you
uh beeps for the blog
now i want to leave you with a couple of
links that i've used throughout this
presentation
an important link that you will find
here highlighted
is a full timeline of milestones in
human microbiota research
published by nature but you will also
find some of the other links that i have
highlighted
in this presentation and these include a
couple of articles review articles
on the current and future topics in
metagenomics and microbiome research as
well as some of the tools
that i briefly mentioned in this program
and in this webinar
okay so as a conclusion
i'm happy to address any of the
questions that i might have missed
so please let me know if you have any
additional questions
about the metagenomic sequencing
microbiome research in human health
or the program that is upcoming
metagenomics comicsologic.com
yes uh elia we have three questions so
one is from
uh shraddha so her question is i think a
person with breast cancer or any other
cancer or disease
have some sets of microbiome niche
compared to normal ones
can it be used as biomarker or
predictive markers
by sequencing and finding out normal
ones
okay so i think as i mentioned there are
and maybe i'll use this opportunity to
maybe demonstrate this so
um if we briefly go
to um sorry if we briefly go to
ncbi and i hope that this is going to be
useful for
the other participants here as well um
let me put this link in chat i'm sure
that most of you are familiar with it
so here you can see on ncbi this is the
national center for biotechnology
information it contains a lot
of different repositories that you can
access
for free so in here you can do a quick
search right so your question is about
breast cancer and microbiome
so i'm going to just search this and see
all the different types of databases
that contain
information on the relationship between
breast cancer and microbiome
so here you can see literature so
different publications
genes proteins clinical and
genomes so here what i would do is i
would go to this
bio project section the bioproject
section
is actually a definition of different
types of projects that have some data
associated with it so you can actually
take a look at the data
so here you can see for example
different types of
brief descriptions okay so here is a
great example
of what your question is about
microbiota of
breast cancer tissue here you have
human metagenome comparative analysis of
breast tumor microbiome in black
non-hispanic and white non-hispanic
women
gut microbiota profiling in patients
with her2 negative metastatic breast
cancer receiving
metronomic chemotherapy the human tumor
microbiome
microbiome of a septically collected
human breast tissue and benign and
malignant disease
so you can see here that there is
a very big diversity of the types of
data sets that you can get for example
you have treatment versus non-treatment
you have different patients maybe at
different
types or subtypes of breast cancer maybe
in different
kind of compounding factors like ethnic
diversity and background
so you really have a variety of data
sets that you can start looking at
to ask these specific questions most of
these
will actually have a publication
associated with it or will describe how
the data was collected and who was
collected by and what it was collected
for
so really you can start looking at some
of these examples
some of them are very recent june 2020
so very up-to-date
some of them might be a little bit older
so here you can see
uh a data set okay also 19th of august
so maybe these don't even have a
publication yet because they're so
recent uh let's take a look over here
weizmann institute of sciences in israel
so
here you also have april 2020. so this
is very cutting edge research i
encourage you to take a look at some of
these examples
and in the program we'll actually do
this kind of analysis together
any other questions
uh yes elia so we have another
question from uh gorov particle
he wants to know if the environment
plays an
important role more than the genetics
for development of the microbiome
because the microbiome study is not done
much in respect to genetics
yeah i think that's an excellent
question so as we see
the microbiome develops in a much more
variable way than genetics and a great
excellent study for this is the um
the study that is called um
they are called twin microbiome
okay so there is a twin uh microbiome
study that recently not so long ago
uh has shown how different
factors actually influence the
development of microbiome in genetically
uh in genetic twins and twins that are
genetically identical right and so that
i think directly answers your question
how the
effect of environment the effect of
uh different preferences for food uh
maybe how they grew up in different
environments
at different stages of their life really
has an
effect on the gut microbiome and i think
that is an excellent place to start
answering your question so probably
i'll just paste the link to this
publication right here
there's a whole project here they have
clinical data microbiome data genetic
data so there's really
a lot of data here to go through if
you're interested in that topic
uh thank you elia and we have one uh
last
question so this one was from
someone whose name is still iphone so
the question is my research scope is on
lung brain
microbiome access using rsv virus on
animal model what bioinformatics
approaches are the most
suitable so of course i would love to
know a little bit
more about your research project you
know just
kind of taking that information from
that brief description
and as i understand you have a virus
um so rsv is a respiratory virus if i
understand correctly and then some of
these viruses
actually replicate in the central
nervous system and
i might imagine that that is the
relationship between
uh the lung and the central nervous
system or the brain that you are
referring to
when we talk about the gut brain axis
it's a little bit different it's the
effect of
how the gut microbiota can cause
changes in behavior or in psychology
so when you talk about a virus a
pathogen that directly affects
neuronal cells or has a path of entry
that goes through multiple organs for
example
intranasal cavity or lungs and then goes
somehow to replicate in the neuron
cells that's very different than the
effect
of a specific condition and perhaps
through
kind of this quorum sensing passed on
to other organs in the body so if you
are looking
at virology you're looking at virus
sequences
viral replication we do have a
completely different program called
bioinformatics for infectious diseases
so bioinformatics for infectious
diseases
um okay so
this is a a program that's actually
starting on november 9th
that i would recommend for you to
explore
here we do talk about the specific tools
for viral sequence analysis so
viral genomics phylogeny of viruses
evolutionary studies of viruses we'll
talk about things like tissue tropism
and how specific mutations in viral
genomes could be associated with the way
that they replicate in different types
of cells
so i think that would be a more suitable
direction
if you're interested in that particular
project that i if i understood it
correctly
okay so again thank you everyone for
joining today's session
uh i am going to stop uh the sharing
if you do have any last questions uh
please do let me know
i would be happy to continue this
conversation
uh we will be starting this program
again on november 17th
and we will have our first couple of
sessions are going to be again open and
free for anyone
so you will be able to join just to
evaluate
and be able to continue in asking these
excellent questions that we've had
in this session so again